alright so you probably think that i'm
completely nuts because of that title
but there's a very real chance that
apple could be ditching
the 11-inch ipad pro for next year's
update and instead just releasing
a larger more expensive 12.9 inch ipad
pro model
with a bunch of huge upgrades so what
i'm gonna do in this video is go through
a bunch of leaks
that point to this actually being a
possibility
and then i'm gonna talk about why it
actually makes sense
for apple to ditch the 11 ipad pro model
and then i'll finish off by discussing
some of the features that we should
expect in
the 12.9 inch ipad pro and one we should
realistically
expected to be released so let's get
started with some of the leaks that go
all the way back
to december of 2019 when ming chaqua
said that a new
12.9 inch ipad pro with a mini led
display
would be coming in the second half of
2020
and then in march of 2020 ming added
more apple devices to the list of
products
getting mini led displays later that
year
that obviously didn't happen because
kovid 19
caused massive delays pushing back all
of the mini led device rumors
into 2021. now what's interesting about
all of those rumors
is that the 11 inch ipad pro is nowhere
to be seen
which is really odd because apple has
recently been updating both
sizes at the same time and then once
again
in september he released another note
yet again ignoring the 11 inch model and
most recently just a couple of days ago
he mentioned that the 12.9 inch ipad pro
with a mini led display
will launch in the first quarter of 2021
but yet again no mention of the 11 inch
this instantly caused multiple mac
rumors users
to suspect that apple is in fact not
releasing an 11 inch ipad pro
alongside the new 12.9 inch model next
year
i also saw a couple of reddit posts with
users wondering the same thing
will apple discontinue the 11 inch ipad
pro
and just keep the larger 12.9 inch model
well i did a bit more digging and found
some very interesting leaks
fudge a leaker with over 90 accuracy
said on june 2nd that ipad pros with an
a14x chip will be coming
basically pointing at two different
sizes right after that
love to dream with an 89 accuracy rating
retweeted
fudge's tweet and added that they'll get
a mini led display
and a 5g modem and then he retweeted
again
stating that they're coming either in
the first or second quarter of 2021
but one thing to note is that he didn't
correct fudge
in terms of whether there will be two or
just one ipad pro model
so in reality there's a chance that the
11 inch ipad pro could be sticking
around
maybe we'll only see a 12.9 inch ipad
pro in march
and then maybe later in 2021 apple will
update the 11 inch model but i
personally find it a bit hard to believe
that they'd split up the release dates
unless they make some major changes
in my personal opinion if apple does end
up
only releasing a 12.9 inch ipad pro in
march
then the 11 inch is dead for good but in
that case
they could be planning to update the
ipad pro at a later date
with a larger display potentially an
11.5 inch display instead of 11.
this would allow them to raise the base
price especially if they add more
features
this would also allow them to create a
larger magic keyboard case
with a more comfortable keyboard instead
of the current
scrunch down version they might even
release the second generation of the
magic keyboard
alongside that new 11.5 inch ipad pro
model
which will further boost sales of that
new ipad pro
on top of that if apple releases only
one
12.9 inch ipad pro in march this would
allow apple to make a lot of money
thanks to the higher base price of 999
dollars
and the massive wave of hype due to it
being the first apple product
to come with a mini led display and also
thanks to the super powerful
a14x chip which i'll get into in just a
second
essentially a lot of people will be
upgrading to this new ipad pro
even if they would have preferred a
smaller 11 inch display
and then at a later date maybe even a
year and a half later
apple would release the 11.5 inch ipad
pro
allowing them to bump up the base price
of that model
now with all of that out of the way i
want to talk about the other reason
why it would actually make sense for
apple to ditch
the 11-inch ipad pro the number one
reason is because apple's new ipad air 4
is extremely similar to the 11-inch ipad
pro
from the front you can't even tell them
apart
and on the back the only noticeable
difference is
the camera bump because of that apple
desperately tried to make the pro
seem better than the air they even went
as far as making the air's display
10.9 inches to make the 11 inch pro seem
just a bit better
they even invested hugely into putting
touch id into the power button
instead of simply giving it face id
which would have been
a less expensive option the ipad air has
4 speaker grilles
but they only put in 2 speakers just to
make the pro
seem better with its quad speakers it's
completely obvious that apple tried very
hard
to make the pro seem more premium and
even still
many users are going for the new ipad
air 4
because it looks basically the same and
the performance is
almost on par because of that it totally
makes sense for apple to ditch the 11
inch ipad pro
and come back stronger with a new 11.5
inch or larger model
with new features and upgrades so that
they can bump up the base price
and that would definitely help
differentiate the
air and the pro and make the whole ipad
lineup
make a lot more sense now i want to
finally get into the 12.9 inch model
and what we should expect from it first
off it's rumored to be the very first
apple product
to come with the new mini led display
and that alone will generate massive
hype and extra sales
if you're not familiar with mini led
technology it basically works
like apple's pro display xdr instead of
having one large led backlight
like all of apple's current ipad and mac
displays use
mini led uses hundreds or thousands of
leds
that light up locally controlled dimming
zones
to offer excellent contrast and colors
similar to an oled display
but without all of its drawbacks many
led displays
actually still use lcd panels so there
will be no burn-in issues
like oleds have and there won't be any
flickering issues
that give some people headaches so
basically
when you watch a movie or video on your
ipad the black bars at the top and
bottom
will actually be black and not gray like
they currently are
and that will actually cause it to save
battery life as well
now moving on to the other features we
can expect the main one
is the a14x chip i've seen a lot of
people claim that the new ipad pro
will come with the m1 chip but that is
dead wrong the m series of chips are
meant to be
exclusive to the mac hence the m
those mac socs come with extra chips
like the i o controller
the thunderbolt controller chips up to
16 gigs of soldered on ram
and other mac related things that the
ipad
simply doesn't need because it only
needs to run the more simple
ipad os software it'll instead come with
the a14x chip
which will basically be a stripped-down
version of the m1
only containing what it needs like the
a-core cpu
the a-core gpu the 16-core neural engine
and other things like the ram and video
encoders
because of that it's going to have
performance similar to the fanless m1
macbook air
but probably a bit worse because the
ipad pro's chassis
is quite a lot thinner than the macbook
air so it's not going to be able to
dissipate heat as well
but nevertheless the performance is
going to be absolutely insane for a
tablet
and there's actually a chance that we
could be seeing apple bring
pro apps like final cut pro over to the
ipad
starting with ipad os 15. and this
actually makes sense
since apple has recently updated those
pro apps
to support apple silicon so it should
technically be able to work on the ipad
with some minor tweaks now as far as
some of the other features
there is a chance that apple could
upgrade the face id sensor
to work better and be smaller
potentially allowing apple
to slim down the bezels by a bit and
with that apple could introduce
multi-user support
which was recently rumored to be coming
soon and it would work
perfectly thanks to face id on the ipad
pro
and touch id on all of the other ipad
models
but other than all of that i don't think
that we should expect apple to change
much else on the 12.9 inch ipad pro
but the one feature i would absolutely
love to see
would be for apple to move the webcam
from the top
to the side so that web conferencing
looks
normal when using the magic keyboard
case so there you guys have it there are
all of my thoughts on the 12.9 inch ipad
pro
and why we could potentially see apple
ditch the 11 inch ipad pro model
if you disagree with me go ahead and
comment below and if you enjoyed this
video tap the like button
click the circle about to subscribe for
more videos like this one
definitely check out one of those two
videos right over there and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]